-Thank you, Jimmy,
for having me, man.
-It's so good to see you.
Come on, you got --
you were kind of grooving
over there when we came in.
-Yeah.
-Just a little --
-Every now and then I got to
give you a funky move.
You know, and The Roots,
you know, they do their thing.
You know.
-God, you got to.
Exactly, right. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You had some like kind of boxing
moves in there.
Are you --
-Oh, yeah.
Were you ever a boxer?
-Yeah, when I was young,
I was a runner-up
in Golden Gloves,
and I was a AAU champion.
-Were you really?
-Yeah.
-Wow, before a comedian
you wanted to be a boxer?
-Yeah, I could do work
with these things, man.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah.
-Did you have a go-to move,
like a good knockout?
-Well, you know, you got the
jab, right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Let me stand up and show you.
You got the jab.
[ Cheers ]
Then you got the right hand.
-Uh-huh.
-And then you got the hook.
-Ooh.
-All right, your hook --
you got to turn that --
you know, turn with it.
So, then when you put it all --
when you put it all together,
you -- pow, pow, boom.
-Boom.
-See that?
See that?
Pow, pow, boom.
-See, I almost walked out and
then you wah, wah, woom.
-Bop. That's it.
-Ooh, that's when I walked away.
-That's the combo. That's
the combo. One, two, three.
-'Cause you fake them out?
You fake them out.
You go like --- you go like,
"Hey, like, what's up?
How you doing?"
[ Laughter ]
And then you're, like bop,
go home.
-There you go.
Hey, what's up? How you doing?
-Go home.
-Yeah, that's it. Yeah.
-There you go.
-That's the way to do it.
That's the move, man.
I can tell.
But you stopped boxing.
Why? Why?
-'Cause I got my eye swollen.
[ Laughter ]
-Just a couple black eyes?
-I came home and I had a big
eye, and my mother said,
"That's it.
No more for you."
And I've been doing comedy
ever since.
-Thank goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank goodness.
You ended up moving to
New York City, right?
-Mm-hmm.
-To do standup and you worked --
Did you work for Sears
telemarketing?
-Sears and Roebuck.
Yes, I was a T.S.R.,
telephone sales representative.
-How was that?
-We used to sell maintenance
agreements.
-Wow.
-So, when you buy new
appliances, we sell warranties
and stuff over the phone,
and I never sold none.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you never --
-No.
-You just call and you go, "Hi,
are you interested in the --"
-Yeah, that's exactly what
I would say --
-Click.
-And they would go, click.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, hang up.
But you had some very
interesting people
working in the cubicle next to
you that were also struggling.
-Yes, Salt-N-Pepa.
-Salt-N-Pepa was next to you
in the cubicle at Sears.
-And that was cool 'cause I used
to mess with them every day,
wouldn't let them get
their work done.
I was always flirting
and everything.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Just making them laugh and just
doing stuff and doing bits?
That's wild.
I heard that they asked you
to open for them for their
first giant New York gig.
-Yes.
-And you did it, right?
-It was a show at somewhere,
I think at the Inferno
or something, and I was supposed
to open for them,
and I got there early.
They weren't there yet.
So they put me downstairs to
wait for them,
and they came and did the show,
and I didn't know,
'cause I fell asleep downstairs.
[ Laughter ]
So when I woke up, I ran
upstairs, they were leaving.
The limo was leaving.
I was like,
"Oh, there goes my chance."
-Wow.
That was -- really?
-Yeah.
-Well, thank goodness
it all turned out great 'cause
you ended up making one of
the funniest TV shows
of all time, "Martin."
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Which we love.
I mean, on top of that, your
standup as well, but I mean,
"Martin" -- this is just some
of the characters you did
on "Martin," and I loved --
-Yeah.
-There's Romey Rome,
there's Sheneneh, Roscoe --
-Yeah.
-Dragon Fly Jones.
Are these based on real people
or just you came up with
just in your head?
-I would say Sheneneh is.
Sheneneh, I would say, I kind of
based off my nieces,
and my sisters and stuff.
Did the attitude.
The, you know, "Oh, my goodness.
Oh, yeah."
They don't take no stuff,
you know?
"Oh, my goodness.
Get out of my face.
I ain't taking no stuff.
I ain't taking no stuff."
You know, that attitude.
That whole, you know.
-Oh, my gosh. Did you know
it was going to take off
and that you know, people would
be still talking about it now?
-I wanted it to. That's why I
did all these characters.
I was trying to do everything
I could to make the show work.
I knew I only had one shot at it
and that's what I did to try
to make it work.
-'Cause so many -- you did it
and you hit it.
[ Applause ]
That was the boom.
That was the knockout.
-Yeah.
Pow!
-Pow. Exactly, yeah.
LeBron James is a big fan of
yours as well,
and I think -- well, he
teamed up with Nike --
was it for his birthday,
I want to say?
-For my birthday.
-For your birthday?
-Yes.
-They made Martin sneakers.
-Yeah.
That was cool, right?
-Look at this, we got them.
[ Audience woos ]
Questlove -- Quest,
you've never seen these?
-No.
-All of your catch phrases
on the back.
I mean, how awesome is this?
Are you kidding me?
-That's cold, man.
I was blown away, man.
I was blown away.
-That is fantastic.
And did you wear them?
Do you ever wear them?
-Uh, yeah. I wore the size that
could fit me, obviously.
These --
[ Laughter ]
These must be LeBron's.
-Like for Shaq, yeah.
-But, yeah, I did
wear them one time.
-It's just -- how cool is that?
I just love any of the people
that respect you like that,
'cause I mean, to get your own
pair of Nikes from
the greatest basketball
player living right now.
-Yes.
-That's pretty cool right there.
-Yes, it is.
-And then, I don't know if you
saw this, but there was an
interview with Kendrick Lamar.
-Mm-hmm.
-Who is, I think one of
the best rappers out there.
-Most definitely.
-And he started talking
about you.
-Mm-hmm.
-And it was a really
funny interview, and he starts
talking about your show,
and the interviewer
doesn't recall --
doesn't know your show.
[ Laughter ]
And he walks out of
the interview.
[ Laughter ]
It's really funny, and we have
a clip of it.
Could we show it?
It's Kendrick Lamar. Watch this.
-I go back and watch "Martin."
-Wait, what did you say?
-Watch "Martin."
Episodes of "Martin."
-What's "Martin?"
-And Fruity Pebbles.
-"Martin." "Martin."
♪ Martin Lawrence
Martin ♪
-Oh, I'm not aware, but I know
Fruity Pebbles.
-Oh --
-Oh [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
-"I know Fruity Pebbles."
-Oh, that's the end --
that's
the end of her career.
-That's it right there, yep.
But, isn't that fun, though?
You have kids coming up
to you now,
like doing all your
catch phrases and --
-It's cool, man. It's cool.
I love it, and I'm just glad.
I'm blessed.
I'm very thankful.